>>Hi this is a conversation with the YouTube
community. Hi everyone. My name is Akin Adesina
and I'm vice president for The Alliance For
A Green Revolution in Africa. Very tough question,
but I think the thing that we first have to
realize is that the world belongs to all of
us and we're actually inheriting it for the
future generation, and therefore we are living
on borrowed time. We have to leave a better
world for the future generations. What can
we do? I think we all have to be responsible
citizens, as governments, as society, as individual,
as corporations and the way that we do are
business is a (inaudible) our resources in
our communities. And clearly you can't do
that alone but we all have to work together.
So the key word is partnership. Work together
to make the world a better place for all,
and especially for our children in the future.
Bye